everybody dion robon here markets
reporter at the wall street journal
thank you so much for being with us on
the live stream today we've got a bunch
of exciting news and information
those of you who are long stocks might
be looking at the market right now
saying oh man again
um but we're going to talk about that
we're going to talk about the uh the
long-term trends in the market as well
as what's going on the bond market we're
going to unpack what data reports we
have coming out this week and get into
what you ought to be looking for if
you're watching the market if you're
following what's going on in the economy
to stay sharp and to stay ahead of those
trends so definitely going to be looking
through all of that thank you so much
for tuning in to this live stream on my
youtube page and and for being with us
on youtube today again i'm dionne robon
thanks so much for being with us i know
you could have been anywhere in the
world but you're here with me so i
appreciate that i want to jump into
everything today i want to first get
started by taking a look at the market
like i said things
not looking great right now on the
equity side we're seeing the vix up
today as the nasdaq is down about 0.8
percent uh the s p 500 down about point
three percent
and the dow down by about point two
percent so we're declining we are off
the lows of the day we were down about
one percent on the nasdaq earlier this
morning um but it seems like we're
bouncing back a little bit so remains to
be seen if we can potentially get some
good news maybe the market ends in the
green today as opposed to in the red but
right now looking like another down day
after another down week in the market
last week
looking over at bonds the 10-year yield
up at 2.86 that means we're continuing
to spike higher on those yields as you
know when yields rise prices fall that's
also bad news for bond investors uh we
are also looking at gold up again
by almost two percent on the wti side
brent crude up by more than two percent
uh
looks like the market might be taking
that as bad news uh natural gas rising
to the highest rate highest price since
2008 i've also got gold up today about
0.75 percent uh for gold checking out
wsj.com so you know it's another down
day another day in the red for markets
and we're you know it's it seems like
that could be a thing we're going to
talk more about that in a minute i want
to get to some of the data that we can
expect today we got the nahb national
association of home builders report on
homebuilder sentiment i'm going to talk
you through that what's going on and
what the big themes are there tomorrow
we get housing starts and building
permits that's going to tell us more
about that housing market which i think
is a really big tell for the economy
right now what's going on in the housing
market and what that's doing to
sentiment for both consumers and for
businesses i think there's a lot to be
picked out there also we get the
existing home sales report on wednesday
so this week is a big week for housing
i'm gonna talk through all of those
explain what they mean what to be
looking out for when we get those
releases as well as what we got this
morning in the nahb home sales index
report
we also get the fed's beige book so this
is going to be i think a big week to
tell us what's going on with the economy
as if you remember if you watched my
live streams we got that expectation or
that call for recession next year from
deutsche bank a couple weeks ago now
we're seeing more and more you know when
i talk to folks on wall street they're
saying you know i'm not calling for a
recession i'm not expecting a recession
but the odds are getting more and more
likely we got that inverted yield curve
a couple weeks ago and that has now
spread back out but that is a
well-tracked and well-known indicator of
recession is correctly predicted or come
before every recession we've seen uh in
the last 70 years or i'm sorry in the
last yeah in the last seven years that's
correct um in the market so
that happened and as that's happened
you've got more and more of these folks
on wall street saying yeah you know the
likelihood of recession is increasing so
definitely worth watching what's
happening in the housing market because
i think that's going to tell you a lot
about what we can expect to see from the
market
and again the fed's beige book that's a
report from business owners uh small
business owners in particular but what
folks are seeing on the ground they talk
to the fed and they tell them hey here's
what we're noticing in the markets
and here's sorry not what we're noticing
in the markets here's what customers are
telling us here's what we're seeing in
terms of our lending here's what we're
seeing in terms of our sales and we get
that report on wednesday from the
federal reserve so that's going to tell
us a lot about the economy definitely
going to want to tune in for that on
wednesday so we're going to be talking
through all of that and more thank you
so much for being with us on the live
stream we've got those housing reports
we've got the feds beige book
and i'm going to be talking through
what's happened with stock and bond
markets and what i think you should be
looking out for and what to expect the
rest of this week so let's dive into the
data right we got some data this morning
i'm coming to you starting at 1 p.m
eastern here on the east coast uh but
you know we already this morning at 10
a.m got that housing report the national
association of home builders with that
housing market index that number showed
a decline for the fourth month in a row
dropping to a reading of 77. uh that
number just important because it tells
you we're still well above that 50
threshold which when things are above 50
that means overall sentiment is strong
it's it's improving it's increasing
when when sentiment is below that 50
index means it's declining so
sentiment's still strong still a solid
number but we're seeing a decline a six
point drop in prospective buyer traffic
to the lowest number we've seen since
last summer that's important because
it's showing us that home builders
confidence is sagging is declining and
has been since december uh since last
year right since the end of last year
well
new supply more homes is what we need
for new supply new supply is supposed to
take some of the pressure off of prices
that continue to rise continue to hit
record highs and we're seeing sentiment
for the guys who build those homes the
guys and gals i should say who built
those homes declining for the fourth
month in a row to the lowest in seven
months that's not a good sign also want
to read a quote from nahb chairman gary
jerry conter
he says quote despite low existing
inventory
builders report sales traffic and
current sales conditions have declined
to their lowest point since last summer
as a sharp jump in mortgage rates and
persistent supply chain disruptions
continue to unsettle the housing market
so again this housing market unsettled
not a good sign even though we are still
seeing those high sentiment ratings at
77 that's still a strong number i want
to read also a quote from nahb chief
economist robert dietz he writes that
while a recession is not forecast to
occur in 2022 the risk of recession next
year is rising pointing again to 2023 i
think that's worth noting and worth
keeping in the back of your mind not a
reason to sell out everything you got
and run for the hills and put the money
in the mattress but
that r word is starting to pop up more
and more and more from folks on wall
street and from folks like nahb
uh so going through this house the
housing reports for this week we just
talked through the nhb
national association of homebuilders uh
homebuilder sentiment report i want to
talk a little bit about housing and
building permits right what those are
is building permits is just the number
of permits that have been authorized to
build a home housing starts is the
number of houses that have been started
how many how many people have actually
started building those houses and we'll
get those numbers on tuesday from the
census bureau and it's nice because
sentiment is one thing but actual
numbers how many houses have actually
gotten started how many permits have
been issued to build houses that's going
to tell us well maybe sentiment's low
and declining but the actual numbers
tell us that things are all right and
what we've seen so far this year we'll
get the report from march on tuesday but
sentiment and sentiment is declining the
actual numbers of permits issued and the
number of houses started has been
holding steady really all year it's not
popping up it's not declining and again
new housing starts mean that there's
more supply meaning more houses for
people to buy which you know when you
get more supply and demand hold steady
that brings prices down so prices right
now are skyrocketing because this supply
issue is not being solved we're going to
see if maybe we get a little bit of
respite on that supply side of things
we're also going to get the existing
home sales report for march on wednesday
that's expected to decline or to slow
down again we've seen a decline every
month since august of 2021
year-over-year so
the year-over-year numbers every month
since august have declined gone
downward
we are also seeing on broadly within the
housing market sales continue to drop
while prices continue to rise that's not
a recipe for a successful housing market
housing economists that i speak to
they don't say they're worried they
think people just have to keep buying
you know because rental prices are
spiking out of control folks don't
really have a lot of alternative they
can either pay a lot more in rent where
they're staying right now or they can
step out and try to buy i remember we
saw last week we did a video on mortgage
rates rising to five percent or an
average of five percent for 30-year
fixed-rate mortgages
that's the highest we've seen since 2018
according to the mortgage bankers
association the highest we've seen since
2011 according to fannie mae or freddie
mac excuse me according to freddie mac a
government associated lender so highest
housing rates we've seen in more than 10
years according to those freddie mac
numbers that's really declining the
number of buyers who can purchase i
talked to nadia evangelou she is the
chief economist or sorry the senior
forecaster for the national association
of realtors she said 16 million people
will be priced out of the market if
rates hold at that 5 level so again very
important to keep track of that so we've
gone through those housing reports what
we can expect to see this week we got
the nahb homebuilder sentiment report
this morning declining that's not good
we will see housing starts and building
permits that's going to tell us what the
actual numbers are on tuesday and then
on wednesday we'll see that existing
home sales report so be sure to keep out
keep a look out for that also wednesday
we get the feds beige book that's when
the fed goes out and they talk to their
you know their their sources in the
market kind of like we journalists do
right go out and they just ask people
what are business conditions like tell
me what things are like for you not just
better worse or the same but you know
how are customers reacting what are your
suppliers telling you what are you
hearing from folks on the ground are
people being able to get loans are they
are they happy with their business or
things picking up are they slowing down
what's it like to hire people
so these conversations about the economy
get released in the feds beige book
that's coming out on wednesday
we'll get to hear a lot about the impact
of higher inflation um whether this
hiring trend is is that slowed down
considerably is continuing or if things
are starting to take a turn around a
corner so that's going to be big i think
on wednesday definitely take a look at
that i also want to talk about the major
themes in the markets for stocks and for
bonds because i think we've got two
very different kinds of markets there
and what i'm hearing from investors and
the folks on wall street that i talk to
about both the stock and the bond market
so want to take a look you know you're
you're with us on the live stream thank
you so much for doing that and for being
with us uh we're going to be doing this
every monday right now going forward at
1 pm eastern so appreciate everyone who
tuned in
when i look out at the stock market
right when you talk about the sell-off
last week and the sell-off the week
before last week at least there wasn't
really a major catalyst for that
sell-off yeah we got that cpi number the
inflation number 8.5 percent the highest
in 40 years again right the month over
month number
um was high but when you looked at that
core numbers and when you take out food
and energy prices which are historically
volatile uh which tend to jump up a lot
more than the rest of the index that
number was only 0.3 percent and that got
a lot of folks talking about the
possibility that we've peaked on
inflation that this last month we got in
march 8.5 percent increase year over
year on the cpi consumer price index
may have been the highest we get and now
we start to gradually decline that was
sort of the the rebound or the reaction
i got that i heard from folks i know on
wall street um
you know when i talked to annetta
markowska she's the chief economist at
td securities she says yeah this is this
the numbers in this report suggest that
we have peaked and now we're starting to
come down we should start to come down
on inflation when we get that report in
may looking back in april they're
expecting folks on wall street the chief
economists who study this that that
report's going to show us we're lower
and then they expect to keep going lower
from there but
with that said we're not expected to get
back to the fed's target of two percent
the fed wants inflation uh to be about
two percent right now it's about eight
percent that's a large drastic
difference and economists aren't
expecting us to get back to that two
percent number anytime soon but again
looking back at how that reflects in the
stock market if the cpi was high but
good news why did we see that sustained
sustained sell-off where stocks ended
the week down 2.1 percent
down for two straight weeks and again
we've seen sustained pressure on the
sailing side and we've got more of a
sell-off going on again today
if you remember last week that was the
start of earnings season really kicking
off and ramping up with some of those
big numbers or the big companies on the
earnings side or on the stock side s p
500 companies largely are beating
expectations uh earnings were pretty
good bank of it bank of america today
came out and beat expectations so that
wasn't the cause for the decline used
banks seeing decreased profit still lots
of profit but many also beat their
expectations and as long as you beat on
earnings that's really what wall street
seems to care about also heard good news
from delta
they're saying they're expecting to
return to profitability that's good news
for the airlines good news for the
consumer facing sector and united health
the other big non-bank company beat
expectation so
we actually saw pretty good news on the
earnings front which is what investors
have said they needed to see and we
still saw that decline in the s p 500
down 2.1 percent the nasdaq down 2.6
percent and that was building off of a
3.9 percent decrease for the nasdaq the
week before so we're seeing a pretty
consistent decline and turn downwards
for the stock market what do we really
need to get that to turn upwards because
we did see solid earnings last week um i
really think it's a lot of uncertainty
investors right now are saying hey you
know what the fed is raising rates uh
central banks around the world are
raising rates we're seeing this
continued high inflation
i want to sit back out sit out a little
bit and see what happens before i put
more money into the market and some are
still selling obviously
you also now have some good places to
hide out right you've got some places to
put your money where you're getting a
little bit of return as we talked about
the 10-year u.s treasury note is
yielding 2.86 percent as of today that's
almost a 3
return on your money or 3 interest rates
that you're getting from the 10-year us
treasury in the risk-free asset as it's
known um
so again that's a that's a reason that
the stock market could be declining as
and a lot of investors say
i don't really see a bull case for
putting money to work right now let me
just hang out and hide a little bit in
the markets the bond market is coming
off its worst quarter in decades uh the
u.s bond aggregate index the the
bloomberg aggregate was down six percent
last quarter in the first quarter of the
year that's the worst quarter since
since 1980 loss of six percent and the
two-year treasury yield uh saw the
highest increase in bond yield since
1984 the five years saw the highest
increase in yields since 1987. so big
numbers you're getting paid a lot more
in that treasury market and we're not
seeing it yet but a lot of the investors
i talk about say maybe it's time to
start getting some treasuries back in
the portfolio maybe it's time to start
getting back into bonds because maybe
we've gone too far too fast again
remember the federal reserve mapped out
a rate of 1.9
for the end of 2022 at their meeting in
march they obviously we're going to hear
more from them in may but we've got a
couple weeks before we hear from that so
maybe it's already gone too too far too
fast the fed only has a 2.4
long term rate for the bond market and
only projected 2.8 percent for 2023 and
2024 so
we're already there we're already at
what the on the 10-year note we're
already at what the fed anticipates the
high will be for 2023 and for 2024 and
well above their expectations for the
long-term rate which we know the 10-year
treasury is a projection of the market
expectations for long-term rates so
we're already above that has the market
gone too far too fast that remains to be
seen
right now when we look at the market
it's saying that it has not come too far
too fast so thank you again for being
with us on the live stream want to do
another market check as i'm looking out
things start continuing to come back the
nasdaq now down about .55
was down about point seven percent when
we started uh the s p 500 now down about
point two percent the dow down about
point one five percent moving back
towards zero or moving back towards even
on the day or being flat so that's where
we are um thank you so much for being
with us on the live stream again i am
deon robon markets reporter for the wall
street journal uh on this live stream
today we've talked about what you should
look forward to this upcoming week right
we got the nahb national association of
home builders report this morning we
already had uh we've already seen that
that declined for a fourth straight
month to the lowest in seven months we
will get tomorrow
housing starts and building permits uh
the report on those from the u.s census
bureau and on wednesday we get existing
home sales that's going to tell us how
many already built homes were sold for
march so a lot of information we'll get
has this rising rate environment march
was the first was the month where we saw
rates just really spike through the roof
and hit that five percent level did that
slow down home buying considerably and
consistently as we've seen and did that
spike prices up higher and continue that
trend so we'll learn that this week we
also get the fed's beige book which is
going to tell us a lot about the economy
and i think we're going to learn a lot
about what investors think about stocks
and bonds in other markets as we've seen
oil up again big today gold also up so
appreciate you being with me today for
the live stream we're going to do this
every monday 1 p.m eastern right here on
my youtube channel thanks to everybody
for tuning in whether you tuned in late
early stay for the whole thing or you
watch this on repeat on my channel on
youtube uh thank you very much for
tuning in uh that's gonna do it please
stick with us and come back again when
we do it again next time right here on
my youtube channel i'm deon robon for
the wall street journal thank you so
much for being with us